[Musique]
étrangère
mélange parfait d'une attitude nord-américaine
à l'enthousiasme et
au bruit vraiment et de l'influence française
parce que la France pour Pink Floyd est une
chose très spéciale,
nous avons eu le soutien du public français à
une époque où dans le reste de l'Europe, ils
n'étaient pas vraiment particulièrement intéressés
mais les Français l'ont absolument compris et je
pense que cela a influencé l'Amérique du Nord,
mettons les applications de shopping en feuilles ne sont pas de
la personnalité, je veux dire les
sections Les
spectateurs
et bien je pense que pour le début pour les premiers
concerts, je ne peux tout simplement pas vraiment m'en souvenir
beaucoup à leur sujet, je veux dire qu'ils l'ont fait il y a
environ 50 ans et je pense que je
devrais l'inventer pour me souvenir de
ces moments spéciaux.
pouvoir cracher 20 mètres
serait même Beyond Roger et c'est donc
un peu apocryphe mais je pense que le
truc important c'est que ce n'est pas
spécifique à Montréal c'est en fait à propos
de la déconnexion entre
le groupe et et euh et un audio d'
énorme audience parce que  nous penserions
apprendre à faire face à des publics d'une
taille qui n'aurait jamais envisagé
[Musique]
euh
c'est intéressant que tu dises ça
à propos de se retenir parce qu'il y a une
croyance qu'il y a une technique et pas
exactement une technique mais un style que
euh les batteurs anglais ont  de
tirer sur le timing alors que
les Américains ont tendance à être soit dessus, soit
presque légèrement en avance et je
suppose que si c'est le cas, alors mes
influences étaient tous ces grands batteurs
de la fin des années 60 au début des années 70, je veux dire que je suis
ici maintenant parce que j'ai vu  Ginger Baker
jouant avec de la crème et j'ai pensé que c'était ce que
j'aimerais faire mais aussi quelqu'un
comme Mitch Mitchell le batteur de Jimi
Hendrix
[Musique]
ton flux en boucle ton flux épique plafonne
la programmation de drogues
Dark Side of the Moon J'aimerais que tu sois
ici au  le mur est que
je pense que d'un point de vue de la drogue,
c'était vraiment l'influence de Sid et
puis
ce que nous avons, je pense
ouais, je pense que ce que nous avons vraiment apprécié, c'est
les aspects techniques de faire un
bon disque et vous ne faites pas ça  sur les
drogues psychédéliques tu le fais en
t'améliorant dans le
travail de la machine et euh je veux dire je
pense que le
côté particulièrement sombre c'est un
travail musical très technique vraiment il n'y a
rien à voir avec le psychédélisme
[Musique]
étrangère
Je pense que la meilleure façon de voir  c'est
d'avoir une vision positive et de dire que s'ils
n'étaient pas des gens aussi difficiles ou complexes,
nous n'aurions rien fait du tout,
nous n'aurions jamais traversé Darkseid ou le
mur ou quoi que ce soit et même si oui, je
ne peux pas faire directement
mais je pense que tu dois juste y aller c'est
comme ça
[Musique]